and so today i want to set out how this
government
will offer a lifetime skills
guarantee to help people train
and retrain at any stage in their lives
and enable us not just to come through
this crisis but to come back stronger
and build that better our economy
has been shaken by kovid and in the
hand-to-mouth
scrabblings of the pandemic the
shortcomings of our labor market
and our educational system have been
painfully apparent
in the last few months i've been touring
labs where people many of them young
are working flat out on testing samples
testing for the disease testing for the
efficacy of potential vaccines testing
the tests and it's hard work it requires
endless patience and good hand-eye
coordination it also requires
an excellent grounding in lab techniques
and in the science and every time
i've been fascinated to find that a
sizeable proportion
of the technicians are from overseas and
although i welcome that because it's one
of the glories
of our education system that it attracts
so many people
from around the world we have to face
the fact
that at this moment when we need them
so much there is a shortage of uk
trained lab technicians just as there is
a shortage
of so many crucial skills
we're short of skilled construction
workers and skilled mechanics and
skilled engineers and we're short of
hundreds of thousands
of ite experts and it's not as though
the market doesn't require these skills
the market will pay richly
the problem is one of supply and somehow
our post 18
educational system is not working in
such a way as to
endow people with those skills
and i don't for a second want to blame
our universities i love
our universities and it's one of this
country's great achievements
massively to expand to have expanded
higher education
but we also need to recognize that a
significant
and growing minority of young people
leave university and work in a
non-graduate job
and end up wondering whether they did
the right thing was it sensible
to rack up that debt on that
degree were they ever given the choice
to look at the more practical options
the courses
just as stimulating that lead more
directly
to well-paid jobs we seem on the one
hand
to have too few of the
right skills for the jobs our economy
creates
and on the other hand too many graduates
with degrees which don't get them the
jobs
that they want and the truth is
we're not giving anywhere near enough of
the right kind of training or support
to the 50 of young people who don't want
to go to university
and so we're depriving them of the
chance to find
their vocation and develop a fulfilling
well-paid career so the result is
business
isn't happy the economy is
underproductive
and many working adults are stuck in
jobs without much future
when they're hungry for new
opportunities
so it's time for change for radical
change
and let's begin by admitting that part
of the problem is that not every
uh fe college non-liberty training
college is as superb
as exeter college uh we need to invest
in skills and we need to invest in nfe
and that's why we're putting 1.5 billion
pounds into upgrading and improving
colleges
across the country fixing the leaky
ceilings bringing forward
200 million pounds this year the
facilities here are awesome i've tried
them myself this morning
and improving all fe is part of our
leveling up agenda to ensure that the
same
quality applies everywhere and as
everybody knows
you can't acquire skills in the
classroom
alone you need to learn
on the job to build up the muscle memory
and not just a theoretical understanding
so i can announce today that we will be
expanding apprenticeships
reforming the system so that unspent
funds can be used more easily
to support apprenticeships not just in
big companies but in the
smes where there's so much potential for
job creation
and we want many more of these
apprenticeships to be
portable so you can take them from
company
to company suppose you're in a small
startup making videos for youtube
and the project ends so you've got to
move to another such
a small company under our plans
you'll be able to take that
apprenticeship to your new employer
and it won't die with the end of the
contract
but if we're going to reform our post 18
education
we must go much further
we've got to end the pointless
nonsensical
gulf that's been fixed for generations
more than a hundred years between the
so-called academic
and the so-called practical varieties of
education
it's absurd to talk about skills
in this limited way everything
is ultimately a a skill of way of of
doing something
faster better more efficiently more
accurately
more confidently whether it's carving or
painting or brickling or writing or
drawing or
mathematics greek philosophy every
single study
can be improved not just by practice
but by teaching so now is the time
to end this bogus distinction between
effie
and hc we're going to change the funding
model
so that it is just as easy to get a
student loan
to do a year of electrical engineering
at an fe college
or do two years of electrical
engineering
as it is to get a loan to do a
three-year degree in politics philosophy
and economics the auger review
highlighted the complexity of the
funding system
the bias that propels young people into
universities and away from technical
education
it's time to end that bias
we will give fe colleges access
to the main student finance system so
that they're better able
to compete with universities not for
every
fe course but for a specific list of
valuable and mainly technical courses
to be agreed with employers and in the
coming years
as part of our lifetime skills guarantee
we will move to a system where
every student will have a flexible
lifelong loan entitlement
to four years of post 18
education and suddenly with that
four-year entitlement
and with the same funding mechanism you
bring universities
and fe closer together
you level up between them and a new
vista of choice opens up
i want every student with the aptitude
and the desire to go to university to
get the support
they need but i also want all young
people to be given
a real choice in life and not to feel
there's only one route
to success at the moment many young
people
feel they have to go for the degree
option they feel they have only one
chance to study and
to borrow they might as well go for the
maximum and get
a degree under our plans
you could go for a one-year technical
qualification and launch yourself
at life or you could do that and then go
to university later on
you have the choice and it will be
easier
for older people to borrow to do courses
locally and to study
and train part-time to acquire the
skills that can transform
their lives and of course we need
this nimbleness now
this flexibility to acquire new skills
because kovid has massively accelerated
changes
that were already happening in the uk
economy
whether in retail or in in restaurant
chains
and while the government is building on
our furlough scheme
and we're devising ever more imaginative
ways to safeguard jobs
and livelihoods including the winter
economy plan
which rishi sunat the chancellor
announced last week
alas as rishi said we cannot
save every job but what we can do
is give everybody give people the skills
to find and create new
and better jobs of the workforce
in twenty thirty ten years from now
the vast majority are already in jobs
right now but a huge number of them
are going to have to change jobs to
change skills
and at the moment if you're over 23 the
state
provides virtually no free training to
help you
in fact we've seen a hemorrhage in the
last 20 years
in adult education a million fewer
than there were we're going to change
that right now
we're expanding the digital boot camps
where you can learn
i.t wherever whatever your age
replicating our highly successful
training camps
in manchester and birmingham in four
more
locations above all from next april
we will introduce a new funding promise
as part of our lifetime skills guarantee
we will now fund
technical courses for adults equivalent
to a level all of which
teach skills that are highly in demand
they'll give anyone who left school
without an a level or equivalent
the qualifications they need when they
need them
when they need them helping people to
change jobs
and find work in the burgeoning new
sectors that this
country is creating so suppose you work
in retail or hospitality and you think
you're going to
find you need to find a new job
and before covid people were already
shopping ever more online already uh
sending out
for food but the crisis has compressed
that revolution so let's imagine that
you're
you're 30 years old and you left school
without a levels and you're thinking
you know you could find a job you were
in retail or hospitality you could find
a job
in the in the wind farm sector in the in
the northeast
or in space technology in in yuki or in
construction
here in in exeter or retrofitting homes
retrofitting homes
so as to reduce carbon
you might see a job for yourself on one
of the vast
engineering and infrastructure projects
that this government
is leading a surveyor or a rail
technician
you might want to work in adult care
crucial sector
for our country you have a range of
options
in theory but you need that technical
know-how you need that a-level
equivalent
qualification and we will fund it we
will give you
the skills you need the british economy
is in the process of huge
and rapid change driven by the internet
and the possibilities of remote
communication but as old types of
employment fall away
new opportunities are opening up with
dizzying
speed vast new sectors in which this
country
already leads or can lead the world and
over the last few centuries there is no
other country that has shown the same
adaptability the same ingenuity
in matching the demands of new
technology
but for the last few decades alas
we have been hamstrung as a country
by a lack of investment in
infrastructure
in science by our antiquated planning
system
and by our failures in technical
education
and this government is putting that
right we're making unprecedented
investments in infrastructure and
doubling the investment in science and
technology from 11 billion pounds
to 22 billion pounds a year by 2024
we're changing the planning rules so
it's easier to provide homes for young
families and
for businesses to grow and invest
and we're transforming the foundations
of the skills
system so everyone has the chance
to train and retrain and
this combination of reforms will tackle
the fundamental problems
in our economy of productivity and
growth
helping the country to invent new
industries
and contribute to humanity's great
challenges from fighting
pandemics to achieving net zero
carbon emissions above all
it will make this country our united
kingdom
richer and it will make our country
fairer
so my message today is at every stage
in your life this government will help
you get the skills
you need through our lifetime skills
guaranteed we'll
upgrade further education colleges
across the country with huge
capital investment we'll expand
apprenticeships
making it easier to get a high quality
apprenticeship and connect them better
to local employers who know
where the jobs of the future are going
to emerge
we'll fund free technical courses for
adults
equivalent to a level extend our digital
boot camps
we'll expand and transform the funding
system
so it's as easy to get a loan for a
higher
technical course as for a university
degree and will enable fe colleges to
access funding
on the same terms as our most famous
universities
and will give everyone a flexible
lifelong loan entitlement
to four years of post 18 education
so adults will be able to retrain with
high level technical courses instead of
being trapped
in unemployment and this long-term plan
learning from what has worked around the
world
will finally enable our amazing country
to close the gap with other countries
that in this one respect
have had or thought they've had the edge
on us when it comes to skills
and technical education they thought
they had the
edge on us for 100 years well we have
the talent
we have the potential all we need to do
is give people the chance
and yes we face a once in a century
pandemic but now is the time
to fix a problem that has plagued this
country
for decades now is the time to end the
pointless snooty and frankly
vacuous distinction between the
practical and the
the practical and the academic and now
is the time
to give everybody with this with this
lifetime
skills guarantee give people of all
ages the means and the confidence
to switch and to get the skills they
need
and now is the time for all of us to
begin
to build back better thank you all
very much indeed for your patience thank
you